The world is coming undone.
Imperial flags reign across the galaxy.
I feel very proud to be
in the business for so many years.
Asians have proven themselves
who are as good as anybody else.
My character is very connected to the
Force and in fact his lines is always
surrounded by connecting with the Force
May the Force be with you... I am the Force.
I just done a lot of research you know
on how to play a very fun,
not just a very typical blind person, he's a
blind warrior that lives in a Star Wars
universe, so I was intended to create
this character very unique and special.
In my films nowadays, no matter what
films that I'm in, y'know, I think
that influences is automatic.
If I'm Donnie, obviously you're gonna see a lot
of Donnie Yen's characteristics in
any role that I play, not just this role.
You see that when I'm fighting, it is part of me.
That time I didn't really want to
leave my home and my children have a lot
to do with it because i asked them,
would you like to see your father in Star Wars.
And of course the answer was "Yes!"
The past Halloween, we wanted to do
a Star Wars theme. It was my wife's idea and we
ask Disney to help me and they
were very generous and they sent me this
exact fabrics from my outfit, sent over
to Hong Kong and had my Hong Kong team to
create the exact outfit for the past
Halloween and then I posted it up on Instagram.
And my daughter was the Stormtrooper.
I don't believe it was created
especially for me, they were looking for
character like that and i believe that
was the reason why they called me.
Well, I think Chirrut, if you give him a
lightsaber, he could take on Darth Vader.
But the producer didn't give me the lightsaber.
I think that stormtroopers, you know for me,
if you could fight 10, you could fight 20... in that world.